I figured it out all on my own already
is she drunk
well what I have realized with my
daughter after I dragged her across the
county when you introduce kind of that
physical energy it changes after you did
drag her across the table it was a WWE
wrestling yeah no we had this happened
at like it was uh like three or four in
the afternoon
this was in the afternoon so this
happened and immediately she gets her
energy from the Sun she's a plant
clearly I'm an earth sign so I get my
energy from the from my body so see
press play
I'm a fire sign so I'm getting I'm
getting energy from this heat perfume
pause
so I and this is something I never do
because I can't I think we're kind of
like using the same way as a single mom
yeah I got this [ __ ] yeah yeah I got it
I ain't calling her dad you can't you
you I'll die starving on the road before
I call her dad so I'm like you know what
I'm all the way
say it again that's the dumbest [ __ ]
ever AJ let him rock out for a little
bit we go digest that we can digest that
later let's rock out go finish the story
okay
I'm gonna die on the side of the road
before I call your dad yeah
that's your ego
that's your ego you're not in it for the
kid you're in need for you for your ego
you're not even looking after your kid
it's all your ego and I don't if you
think like that about the baby dad I
don't even know what you're saying about
the baby it add to the kid but we don't
know about that so we're not gonna go on
that but that's your ego that's not you
being a mother that's you being an
egotistical [ __ ] that's what it is
let's hear you [ __ ] let's hear why he
might be he might be a convict in prison
we don't know
we don't know
let's hear a lot I like to give people
the benefit of the doubt preach does it
peace
you've been holding that [ __ ] down from
the start to the beginning and you've
been setting and implementing every seed
that that child has in them without the
help of the other I don't need to call
you for nothing so period I say
respectfully that actually gives me the
value for my questions
I don't know the relationship between
you and her dad so when you say I would
die on the side of the road a group of
y'all and how these dads operate because
it's not just us respect okay no no it's
a large percentage it's a large
percentage of women who has to take on
that a whole package of course I'm
saying without the other party of not my
choice
no no Matt no no that's not even joking
like that matter love for him my mom's
was a single mom so I say that because
when you when you introduce Dad I'm
assuming that he's in her life so when
you say that I would I agree on this
it's always to a degree
though because men get a lot of choices
and I don't think we want to talk about
that but it's always Twitter okay
we haven't heard her take so press play
yo why are you looking at y'all mad and
[ __ ]
don't look at me all upset
give that energy to her don't give it to
me oh it's coming okay okay okay but you
give me that answer that's weird bro
press press play
yeah yeah because yeah it is you being a
egotistical yeah me and her okay get her
energy from the Sun
yeah yeah earth science [ __ ] Taurus
baby Taurus seasons
foreign
what
pause if you're a parent how you gonna
tell me I can't this weekend next
weekend
because parents don't do that listen I'm
not here to it's every weekend
every Monday through Saturday Sunday
it's every day 24 7 365. it ain't no not
this weekend I can't I'ma let y'all
listen I'm gonna let y'all get y'all
I don't
you just sitting there smiling my woman
said you're well trained
what is this podcast bro
[ __ ] that couldn't be me
does this man just sit there and smile
while they said this man's well trained
foreign
what's good my people I got a confession
to make yeah I have
kind of a phobia of not smelling good
and I got a lot of fragrances at home
and I know what you're saying the
fragrance world and the perfume world is
a hard world to dig into because so many
choices uh what do we do what do I
choose from I got the thing for you
Sandberg what is Sandberg it's a it's a
subscription based company that sends
you samples of perfume you get a
fraction of a bottle you bid a fraction
of a price cute little samples like
these right here it's really simple to
use you just have to roll it out and
Spritz it out and you're good to go you
see you can choose different fragrance
oh this one is good what is that I think
it's Man by Mercy yeah that's Man by
Mercedes Benz anyways you choose all
these fragrances and then you can you
can stop your subscription whenever you
want click on the link below right now
and get your 55 by using Albert preach 4
and get on Sandberg today
unfortunately it's generational no you
say it's not personal but I'm sure the
[ __ ] that's watching this that's the
dad is taking it very personal let me
answer that question what it says so
I'll finish that story so I realize that
you know obviously I done dragged her
across the floor she's crying the dog
crying like it's it's just but I
realized that I was here and not able to
you know fully think through the
rational calm this is a good time to tag
team because I'm I'm here yeah and I'm
literally I'm stuttering I'm spitting
you've got to throw over like a while
ago yeah we're here so this is a good
time to tag team my partner yeah damn
keep going I got so I gotta ask a
question questions for Jay so I said
Jake uh my daughter well whatever we
already said our name Jay I said call
Daddy right now and this is one thing we
do yeah I like I do call him daddy he
calls me Mommy so I said call Daddy
right now
so she called Daddy
as soon as he picked up she's like
he said put dad
so he gets on the phone with me he said
what happened I told him what happened
he said take a breath
which I appreciate it because I did need
to calm down
and he said what happened I told him
what happened and he said you know
y'all both in there y'all both women
you're gonna get into this little
situation but take a breath remember
she's still a child she still is
learning lessons
let me talk to her so then I gave the
phone nobody nobody said that I mean
between the lines a couple seconds
maybe he a good father maybe not a good
[ __ ] no no a few seconds away before
y'all made it seem like hey hey
you didn't drop a gem dude you're a
[ __ ] Cooper maybe he's a good dad
he's not a good [ __ ] but you'll still
call them to be able to reconcile
situations and and lean on him for
advice in regards to how to handle
parenting and even just your own [ __ ]
hyperventilation what are y'all talking
about
this dude is he [ __ ] one of these
women because he's brown-nosing so hard
they out here talking about he well
trained he do seem like a well-trained
labrador am I crazy
there's a lot of dysfunction right here
am I crazy
well it's hard to follow because one is
always interjecting which
basically her and her daughter got into
a tussle yeah I understand I understand
where the [ __ ] I that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying
it's hard to follow because one is
always interjecting but first I got the
black woman being like that's what I'm
that's that's what I yeah the back the
back vocal back vocal back vocal artist
tell him sis it's generational shoe up
like she's stupid
[Music]
okay okay so you know what I mean so
she's always
interjecting and [ __ ] so uh and after
that like so so I get very disarmendous
disinterested when I get that it happens
more than that I'm like so what was your
point
you you say you would die on you would
you you
said you know what I'll take back what I
said no it's not ego
and you're not egotistical
you a damn liar
you want to make it look like you
wouldn't call him
that's what the [ __ ] you just did though
why would you lie though
because the ego yeah I'm so proud of you
for giving back to your original point
no but I'm not gonna it's not it's ego
but it's not ego the same way I said it
was ego it's a different type of ego
ego's still there but it's not our first
intended it she's not a bad mother she's
not a bad mother she's not just not here
for her she's there for you she you
there for your daughter you are but you
want to claim that you got this [ __ ] so
much and you see like your ad-lib singer
was saying uh at 365 seven days a week
24 7.
but in reality it's not
because you do call him but you're gonna
say nah I would never call him because I
don't need you do call him emotionally
you do call him you just did call your
dad for your daughter to talk to her
that that's him helping you
so you do call him you make you look
like you don't call him and you would
never get caught dead calling him for
help that's a lie that's a whole last
lie because literally 30 seconds later
you did call yeah I miss perspective
it's the truth hey I don't think people
understand that I think I just dropped
the gym what's the gym I said he might
be a good father but not a good [ __ ]
and that's how we have it period they
don't got [ __ ] to do with you so then he
said okay
good for your kid bro right and that's
all that matters
okay if he's a bad [ __ ] and a good a
good father then you should call him
that ain't got nothing to do with
raising the kids
take this one this man really thought he
dropped a gem if he's a good father then
if you're in a dark situation you call
him because he'll help you because your
good father and he wants his mother to
be around
that's it that's all there is that's all
there is no I'ma tell you why okay so
when we talked about when you said you
know your common is Asana or uh Stupid
whatever you said about if I was on the
side of the road I wouldn't call him
right yeah you said you would die you
want a side of the road before I call
him I said that's the dumbest thing I've
ever heard yeah because clearly he's a
good father because of me I figured it
out all on my own already is she drunk
I figured out all on my own already but
I called him in a moment of Crisis
because I needed to hear some words from
him is she drunk hey man listen listen
you know what we're gonna get to her in
a minute and for me who's had this child
on my back okay for 11 going on 12
because you're pregnant for a year so 12
years okay where we have been down we've
lived here we've eaten this we've done
that I've had to rob Peter to pay Paul
to get this
I take my daughter out of the country
every year for her birthday we live in a
house we got a dog I drive Alexis like I
met Jasmine she was living in the Trap
that's not gonna [ __ ] up what I said
doesn't take away from your motherhood
at all okay okay but what matters with
the thinking and I think that's where
and I think that's the difference and
that's what I'm saying exactly it feels
like to me and again I had to talk to my
mother about this and realized what it
was and I just realized you know I
haven't had that amount growth yet yeah
it is to your point maybe it's a growth
maybe it's an ego maybe it's a whatever
I [ __ ] with that but to what I said I
would rather die on the side of the road
then ask that [ __ ] so let me ask you
okay no keep playing because we're about
to get with in there we're about to get
to her in a minute that's what you said
we heard her reason
we haven't heard [ __ ] you haven't said
[ __ ] appreciate it earlier
yeah he he had a dental rights
if you would rather die
of pride
then call the father your child leaving
your child without their mother
you're shitty at your job
people say this my child comes first my
child comes first all right then call
the dad I'd rather kill my
really
what happened to the child comes first
amen listen one can both do two things
at the same time
recognize that you do a lot of the labor
that this may be an unfair disposition
to the labor and recognize it look like
that's [ __ ] okay two and two
recognize that your perspective on this
is incredibly toxic and I can only
imagine how it permeates your child the
way that you talk unbelievable
and the way the dude on the other side
is brown nosing for these women the way
the other girl is like just high-fiving
that dysfunction that's the reason why
she probably don't want to learn the
first time she has any introspection
about is when the guy says it's the
dumbest thing I've ever heard but her
whole life she heard other women say yes
Queen you right [ __ ] we got this ladies
only we don't need these [ __ ] well you
you me you you the New Year blah blah
blah shut up
what are we talking about
this is all dysfunction you got people
who are hyper dysfunctional on a mic
talking crazy about family structures
but sometimes the dysfunction is their
normal you out here fighting with your
child
brush these people are weird bro
these people are weird just
dysfunctional
but when you're raised by dysfunctional
that's your normal that's what you know
that's what you know weird bro and mind
you you set a point uh earlier on
um
I take her to the country I got a Lexus
I got this I got that we got a dog
whatever cable [ __ ] this that knick
knack paddy whack give a dog a bone you
can still be dysfunctional
and none of that I'm new I've known the
richest [ __ ] in the world I've
known some of the richest [ __ ]
in the world
they would they didn't miss anything
technically broken
[ __ ] broken
so I feel like when do you guys trust
your step the step parent in making the
decisions for your child so what I will
say yeah it's not just that I carry this
child for nine months like I know this
child it's more than the carrier well
you know one thing that parents make a
big mistake of is things that they
always know best
right and so they have this
infallibility that makes them make
extremely poor discussions traumatizing
their kids into their late adulthood and
that's why a lot of these kids come out
having a tremendous amount of resentment
for their parents
we go on them and their inability to
look at themselves or recognize that
they [ __ ] some things up is what drives
a lot of the relationships apart and I
think God every single day that my mom
has had the foresight to learn from her
mistake even her older ears to apologize
for someone to be here that she did
because a lot of it was inexcusable
right
and I respect her more for it this ego
that a lot of parents have thinking they
know everything and that they're
infallible is what makes a lot of their
kids resent them and have traumatic
experiences Mama Knows Best not always
not always
unfortunately not always and that's not
a knock against her she can't know best
it's okay to be vulnerable and that's it
you can't be perfect and trying
oftentimes leads to bad outcomes there's
some people out there you're going to
argue with them some [ __ ] and that their
their point that their argument is going
to be yes but I'm her mother
yes but I'm his father
well it doesn't change the fact that
what you just said was incredibly stupid
doesn't change anything of that but
whatever hey
hey you know what what that that's
that's why a lot of [ __ ] go to
therapy oh yeah that's one of the big
reasons why people go to therapy people
think they know more than they actually
do and walk through life like they [ __ ]
don't stink not recognizing [ __ ] you
stinking up the whole joint well we
rocking the club
that's you we smell
that's your ass
you out here looking like oh somebody
shout out here [ __ ] you the [ __ ] and
not in a good way your [ __ ] no no it's
just it's unfortunate it's unfortunate
because a lot of parents try to turn
their kids around the other a lot of
parents be saying crazy things about the
other parent that's generally
undeserving because they got a problem
with them not recognizing that their own
personal biases are coming between their
child's well-being and their parents
relationship
you always say like the child comes from
the child comes first dad comes in [ __ ]
that [ __ ] [ __ ] my kid because my
feelings come first that's what y'all
doing but you won't admit it I could do
all bad by myself okay here you go okay
I make it back vocal hey man hey man
listen you know
often times we always talk about the
systemic issues when it comes to a lot
of this stuff but a lot of this [ __ ]
comes down to the individuals and how
they handle their relations oh yeah
definitely and you know what the fake
that you talk to your mom and you had
reflection and you still came to that
same conclusion probably leads me to
believe that this [ __ ] is generational
what you mean her Mama Knows Best
the same way she knows best and she out
here on this podcast spouting out
[ __ ] while she got a kid now she
what in her 30s crazy
dysfunction At His Highest but I digress
maybe we saw it wrong maybe you guys see
it differently let us know in the
comments below